this is a battle we actually have
with the entire developing world where
we know there are some countries
that have vaccinated well over 40 50
percent
of their adult population are now
vaccinating even teenagers
and on top of that have surpluses 40 50
million doses
but are still not ready
to share that with the rest of the world
that
is is is is is is the height like i said
of a nationalism that really has to be
dealt with and this is something
we are fighting and we're going to fight
day and night until we ensure
that there is equity in the provision of
these reuters
gave these figures they said during the
last week reported
kenya averaged about 7 306 doses
administered each day
at that rate it will take a further 1440
days
to administer enough doses for another
10 of the population
how does that make you feel when the
head of your vaccine task force says
we have the money we have the money to
buy the vaccines
but we can't get them because they've
been reserved by the rich nation
one of the things that
really has shown how unequal
this world is has been the kind of
vaccine nationalism
that we have seen where
we have and i've stated this openly and
severally
worked together you know when they were
doing clinical trials when they were
doing the research into some of these
vaccines
and then all of a sudden we find
ourselves
unable to access those same vaccines
and this is not just kenya it is
basically
the entire developing world and i think
this is something that
really really needs to be looked at
because
the fact of the matter is nobody not
here in the uk
not in the united states not in germany
nobody is going to be safe until
everybody is safe
and we need to be able to come up with
a way of ensuring that there is going to
be equity
in the distribution of these vaccines